Hi, Mystery Recapped here. Today I am
going to explain a short film called
“2081” Spoilers ahead! Watch out and take care!
The movie begins with a narration in
the background that the year is 2081
and finally everyone is equal in every sector.
People aren’t equal just by law or God,
they are now equal in each and every
way. Nobody is smarter, better looking,
quicker, or stronger than anybody else. The
narration continues saying that all equality
is possible because of the 211th, 212th, and 213th
amendments done to the constitution of the state.
It was only possible because of the unceasing
vigilance of the United States Handicapper
General. The strong people are compelled to
wear more weight to make them feel weaker,
The intelligent wear earpieces that frequently
fire radio noises to keep them away from taking
unfair advantage of their brain, and the
Beautiful people wear masks in places where
their beauty can be found distracting. It
is called the golden age of equality.
Despite all the equality, some things
about living are still not right. We are
then taken back to a scene where some police
officers barge inside a house to take away a
guy in front of his eldery parents.
Back in the present, the guy’s father;
George Bergeron, is trying to fix the TV
signal. Since he is wearing the earpieces too,
he can barely remember about his son
being taken away by the government.
As he is distracted by small flashbacks of his son
being dragged out, his wife Hazel reminds him that
he has to fix the TV. He then inserts a tube-like
device behind the television to start it.
The television is showing a graceful ballet dance
being performed by a group of beautiful ladies.
The ladies are dancing while wearing
some weights around their necks and
arms. They are also wearing masks, so
that they don’t look superior to anyone.
Meanwhile, George is again having some flashbacks
about the past. But as he tries to remember more
about the incident, the interference from the
earpiece cuts him off. His wife is also able
to hear the distracting noise and asks him how it
was to which George replies that it was loud.
She mentions that she heard the sound of someone
hitting a milk bottle with a ball-pein hammer. She
also adds that it must be good to hear different
sounds every day. George replies that it isn't
pleasing as it disturbs him. Hazel further
adds that if she was the Handicapper General,
she would add the noise of the chimes which would
be pleasing to hear and would also honor the
religion. She also thinks that she would make a
good Handicapper General and George agrees to her
instinct. On the television, we can still see the
beautiful girls performing the ballet dance.
After some time, George again has the visions
of the policemen taking away his son, Harrison
forcefully. But just like the previous times,
he is distracted by the noise in his earpiece.
Seeing this, Hazel feels that he is just tired
and suggests he could take some rest by placing
the handicaps on the pillows. She thinks that
he always seems to be worn out and wants to
make him feel lightheaded in any way possible.
However, George immediately denies her request
and tells her that if he takes the handicaps
off for once, he will feel like keeping them off
every time. He also reminds her how she
would feel if he is without the handicaps.
Hazel replies that she would hate it and he
answers that they can't do anything about that.
Here, we get to know that removing any form of
disability is a crime by law. Hence, everyone
has to abide by the rules, even at home.
Meanwhile, the ballet dance program on the
television is interrupted to present breaking
news. Hazel gets mad due to the interruption
for presenting the same old news. As the news
reporter tries to present the breaking news,
he stammers continuously because of which
the broadcast is stopped for a while.
Despite the wasted effort, Hazel feels that the
news reporter tried his best to present the news
and his salary must be increased by looking at
his efforts. This implies that all the citizens
have been brainwashed into acting equal. Even
inside home, they show traits of equality.
After this, Hazel gets up from the couch and
heads into the kitchen to get the dishes done.
While she is doing the dishes, the news resumes
with a new news reporter. He says that they have
received a warning from the Handicapper General
that a suspected anarchist Harrison Bergeron has
escaped from the police custody. He presents
that Harrison was arrested 6 years ago for
propagandist vandalism, broadcast piracy, refusal
to report his quarterly handicapping evaluations,
and a blatant removal of his handicaps in a
public place. Despite the fact that Bergeron
was in tight security, he vanished miraculously.
The reporter advises the public to be aware of him
as he is a genius and an athlete who is ‘under
handicapped’ and extremely dangerous. While George
is listening to the news carefully, Hazel can’t
hear it due to the water flowing from the tap.
The reporter then concludes his report
requesting the public to contact the local
authorities if they see Harrison nearby.
After the news is over, the ballet dancing
program continues. Suddenly, the ballet girls
start to hear some thumping sound. This is heard
by everyone through the television too. George
quickly recognizes the sound to be of his son
Harrison and utters his name. Harrison appears
with all his body chained, dragging one of the
security guards to the stage. After reaching
the stage, he starts urging everyone present
there to be silent and to listen to him. He
leaves the security guard he was grabbing and
tells everyone that there is a bomb underneath
the building whose detonator is in his hands.
The other security guards are seen approaching
him from behind but as soon as he takes out the
detonator they run away from the stage. Harrison
then strongly suggests everyone to remain
in their seats. In the kitchen, Hazel is still
washing the dishes and is completely unaware about
the incidents happening on the television.
At the theater, Harrison stomps his leg loudly on
the ground and apologizes with everyone present
there for interrupting their entertainment.
He adds that hopefully he could provide
some sort of entertainment by himself.
He then introduces himself and mentions that he
is a fugitive, a public threat and an abomination
of the able. He also mentions himself as the
greatest man anyone has ‘never known’.
Harrison further reveals that he has been held
prisoner by the state for the last 6 years
without any trial and with torture which has no
end. He explains that the state tried to destroy
every trace of extraordinary lying inside
him but they were unable to do so. He says
that he is standing in front of them
being beaten, hobbled and sickened, but
not broken. Harrison then says that they must
destroy the enemy who is hiding in the darkness.
He suggests everyone to shine their lights so that
all the world can notice them. After finishing his
speech, he rips apart his handicaps and throws
them on the floor. The audience in the theatre
are astounded by this as they have been blinded by
the government. At home, George is shocked to see
his son doing all this on television. Meanwhile,
Hazel is still busy doing the dishes.
In the next scene, as a guy escapes the theater,
he comes across a battalion of armed police forces
along with the Handicapper General. The head
officer asks the bomb dispoal team about the
status of the bomb to which they reply that
they will need some time to work it out.
We also see that various groups of the police
forces are placed at different locations.
Inside the theatre, Harrison asks for a volunteer
to display his next trick. When no one from the
audience accepts to be his volunteer, he turns
his head towards the group of ballet dancers.
One of the ballet dancers reluctantly
accepts and starts removing her handicaps.
When she approaches Harrison, he removes her
mask and whispers something into her ears.
He then asks the musicians to play some music.
Outside, the police force is ready to enter the
theatre. Just then, group E of the police force,
the bomb specialists, inform the head officer
that the bomb has been successfully disarmed.
The head officer then contacts the television
broadcaster to stop the live broadcast.
Back inside the theatre, Harrison is listening to
the music played by live musicians but he suddenly
asks them to stop. He then orders one of the
Cellists to play the violin for him. The Cellist
obliges in fear and starts playing the violin
gracefully. The music soothes everyone present in
the audience. At home, George is also enjoying the
music being played. However, his joy turns into
grief as the broadcast is stopped unexpectedly.
The head officer also receives a message from
the broadcasting unit that the live broadcast
has been stopped. He then orders all of his units
to stand by for entry into the theatre. Inside,
Harrison starts dancing with the ballerina,
while holding the detonator in his hands.
As he senses that the troops are about to enter,
he presses the detonator, which activates one
of the systems underground. While this doesn’t
blow anything up, it resumes the interrupted TV
broadcast once again. Seeing his son back
on TV again, George’s face lights up.
Meanwhile, Harrison and the ballerina continue
dancing while the police force and the Handicapper
General enter the theatre. She takes the head
officer’s gun and marches towards Harrison.
Just then, the head officer finds out through his
earpiece that the event is being broadcasted live.
He quickly rushes to stop the Handicapper General
but it’s too late. Harrison is shot by the lady
and he lies flat on the stage.The head
officer reaches the stage and the general
finally realizes that she is on air.
The television broadcast also ends
and Hazel finally finishes doing her dishes.
George is distraught by what he saw but when he
tries to think more of it, he is interrupted
by the loud frequency from his earpiece.
When Hazel asks what’s wrong, he simply replies
that he doesn’t remember but he saw something
sad on the television. Hazel then suggests that
he forget sad things like she always does. The
movie ends as a confused George gets up to get
some drinks from the refrigerator, while Hazel
hums the music from the ballet dance.
This film represents the future
where equality has become dominant but at the
same time, freedom has become non-existent.
Anyone promoting freedom is apprehended
and punished, just like Harrison was.
What’s scary is that the way our society is
progressing, this sci-fi short movie may turn out
to be real in the not so distant future. People
have been unfairly demanding equality despite
lacking the ability to match other deserving
candidates. The time may come when even the
intelligent and gifted people may not be
able to showcase their talents. World where
everything is Equal, but no Freedom.
Subscribe for more videos like this, turn
on the notification, and leave a like to help the
channel out. Thank You for watching.